guten morgen hier bei wild life und wir
beginnen mit folgender breaking news
zwei eurofighter der deutschen
bundeswehr haben ein russisches
aufklärungsflugzeug von der insel rügen
abgedrängt die maschine war in
internationalen luftraum gesichtet
worden zuletzt gab es ähnliche vorfälle
in dänemark und schweden die russische
maschine sei im internationalen luftraum
vor der insel rügen identifiziert worden
heißt es und die alarmrotte aus den zwei
deutschen maschinen begleitete das
russische flugzeug im internationalen
luftraum dann weg von deutschland
und sobald es mehr dazu gibt werden wir
natürlich darüber berichten